mom's let me mom sleep mom's tummy in
anal geez ik like Jesus but where's the
anus and first hey everyone I'm Abby
shower welcome to Abby's kitchen it is
almost Mother's Day so in celebration I
want to bring you a special momma and
baby themed Ridiculist
yes we are back again and if you haven't
watched my other ridiculous videos you
should check out the playlist right here
and don't forget to subscribe to get a
lot more crazy [ __ ] coming down the
pipeline in a few videos to come first
up is nursery water so most parents
probably remember that in the first 4
months of life its recommend that you
boil any water that you're giving to
baby to make formula and this new
nursery water is apparently a convenient
way to skip that step except for it's
not so if you look closely at this it's
basically just bottled distilled water
with a cube baby's face on top of course
and a higher price tag seventeen dollars
per gallon naturally it's also not
sterile so theoretically you still have
to boil this water for babies is it a
marketing ploy yes and potentially more
problematically it's another piece of
plastic in our landfill so Mama's let me
tell you you can skip the overpriced
water and save your money and our
environment next okay so next is the
baby pod vaginal speakers I think I need
some vodka in here so here's what we
know about this imagine for just like a
hot minute
putting an earphone up here vajayjay
while pregnant and then hooking it up to
your iPhone and letting your baby rock
out to t-swift
[Music]
because it's never too early to start
grooming your kid for their first talent
show just asking for a nice yeast
infection so apparently according to
research by the 26th week of pregnancy a
baby in utero can respond to
intravaginal music which is what the ear
phone is by moving their mouths and
tongues as a form of early communication
and the thinking goes that this may
stimulate language early on hmm well
honestly as a science and a music buff
this sounds pretty cool to me I'm like
rocking out on the science here but I
have to say 750 dollars for this
earphone or like vagina foam
I guess seems like the epitome of extra
when it comes to baby gear I would be
pretty embarrassed to like put this on
my baby registry just saying grandma
would be like this generation this
generate we didn't have no vagina pods
we just listen to Mozart
now I think it's easy first moms to feel
like we need to buy every educational
device and book and toy out there to
help our kids get ahead but like they're
not even born yet
let's give Tiny Tim like a hot minute to
chilled up out and he's got a whole life
ahead of him to study Mozart or Zeppelin
move along amber teething necklaces
there's a lot of these ugly-ass
necklaces online that are basically
promising a lot more than just a fashion
statement for your little one so
according to the internet these Dix's
are made at a Baltic amber and
apparently release a cynic acid which is
then absorbed into the bloodstream to
act as a natural analgesic for swollen
sore gums fans also claim that they help
control drooling and inflammation of the
entire neck ear throat digestive and
respiratory systems all from a seventeen
dollar not surprisingly there's really
no research to back up any of these
claims and if you're thinking hey what's
the harm it's worth a shot to avoid
toxic pharmaceuticals think again the
American Academy of Pediatrics warns
against infants wearing any jewelry of
any kind especially those with teeny
tiny beads like these ones which pose a
perfect choking and strangulation risk
so what is a better safer alternative
that is just as natural for teething
honestly you could try one of the
millions of silicone teething toys that
are available out there lots of cold
stuff like frozen bananas and a mesh
feeder often works really well for me or
of course lots of cuddles in love yes
teething happens it happens a lot
unfortunately but I would rather be safe
than sorry next okay next is the pro
child diaper alarm baby Bluetooth smart
phone connection urination there's a lot
that this got cut off
connection urination that's how they've
called it okay so next on ridiculous is
the pro child diaper alarm baby
bluetooth smart phone connection
urination the title needs work but
basically for $38 this is described on
Amazon as a diaper alarm for busy
housewives they're selling me on it
already to protect your baby's bottoms
so you connect your smart phones to
check your baby's urine patterns on our
calendar essentially it's a little
wearable device that is Bluetooth 4.0
technology that attaches to baby's
diaper and alarm smother when it's time
change their nappy sounds great I've
seen a lot of these kind of products
online most of which are defunct but I'm
kind of surprised that they even got
greenlit in the first place first of all
most diapers now that I'm aware of have
an indicator strip that let you know
when they're wet so unless you're like
letting baby hang out in one wing your
house and waiting waiting for your text
update that it's time to go without even
looking at him
it's kind of obsolete second uh
especially in those first few months
babies need their diaper changed a lot
and in my experience babies don't like
their diaper being changed so you've got
to do it and fast and the thought of
having to not only take off clothes and
put a diaper on but then also strap on
these devices on while your kid is
losing there seems like unnecessary
torture to me not to mention I don't
know if I like the idea of Bluetooth
technology hanging out anywhere near my
kids junk I mean cell phone manuals
actually tell you to keep your cell
phone away from your gonads which have
literally no protection from the radio
waves so this seems to me like a rather
unsafe idea I am all for parenting
shortcuts but this one seems like more
of a headache than a hack so I'm taking
a hard pass at this next so next on the
ridiculous is this chummy baby lasso
like like like this kind of lasso
honestly whoever invented this has never
changed a diaper
so the baby lasso is supposed to control
and reduce your baby's movements so you
have both hands-free to clean your baby
as a mom of a very active one-year-old
who often uses diaper changing
opportunities as a way to practice his
dance moves this sounds quite promising
and exciting to me however when I
actually think about the logistics
involved I realized what a joke it is
first of all if you think wiping your
kids ass is hard try keeping him on his
back while you actually try to tie his
legs up into these harnesses unnecessary
next these harnesses dangle the legs
down they don't spread the legs open
like the stirrups at the OB and
newsflash any blowit is gonna require
you to spread those cheeks move the
balls around and get into every little
wrinkly skin fold to make sure you do a
proper thorough job and third as one of
the comet responded out hilariously this
harness positions baby's legs right in
line with our tender milk filled breasts
the perfect baby shower gift for adding
insult to injury
next and finally on the ridiculous
PP TPS it's a dick hat it is a chapeau
l'épée nice PPT peas so cute and it
seems like everyone is trying to make
diaper-changing easier out there but in
my limited experience as a parent I
would say that changing diapers is like
the easiest part of parenting everyone
is cracking jokes about how much it
sucks to change a diaper but you know
what sucks more breastfeeding colic
sleep training a sick baby just trying
to entertain a goddamn one-year-old when
you're exhausted I love being a mom but
seriously folks there are bigger
struggles and hurdles ahead okay so
these are surprisingly popular as I've
already seen them on a lot of mom baby
registries however as a boy mom who's
being peed on and [ __ ] on a lot I can
say that having to strap a dick hat on
every single time I change a diaper
would be a hell of a lot more of an
Incan beans than having to change my
shirt every once in a while
honestly I think being peed on mid
diaper change is a bit of a rite of
passage first moms of boys and does not
even happen that much I've had way way
way more diaper leaks than I have had
full-on water fountain style whizzes
well I'm changing a diaper let me let
you in on a tiny tip from a relatively
inexperienced mom the key to a painless
diaper change is speed and if you have
time to trap your kids long in a cone
without getting pissed on you have time
to fold the diaper on without having to
then wash something else
moms and dads you can save your money
and your time and just work on your
diapering speeds well mom's I think it's
safe to say that there is a lot of crap
out there that we do not need when I
think our list could pretty much be
narrowed down to an occasional massage a
nice dinner out with the hubby and of
course lots of coffee so if you loved
this video be sure to give it the thumbs
up Leaney a comment below with some of
the most ridiculous things that you've
seen on the internet whether it's mom
things baby things any other wellness
product I want to hear about it for a
future
Nicholas episode subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen by
[Music]